[Music]
neurobiologically the single most
important fact about say a 20 year old
brain is the fact that almost all of it
is already matured fully wired up
myelinated jargony term for it the
reward dopamine system has been going
full blast since somewhere around like
early puberty all of the brain is
totally up to speed except for the
frontal cortex probably the most
interesting fact about human development
is the frontal cortex is the last part
of the brain to fully mature it is not
completely online until you're about 25
years old which is mind-boggling to
think about what does that explain that
explains why adolescents are adolescent
in their behavior
the sensation-seeking and the
risk-taking and the highs are higher and
the lows are lower because the steadying
frontal cortical hand there isn't fully
up to speed yet and everything else is a
gyroscope out of control and that's
where the impulsivity is from and that's
where the extremes of behavior and
that's why most crime is committed by
people at a stage whose frontal cortex
is not fully developed yet that is why
most people who do astonishing
wondrously self-sacrificial things don't
have a frontal cortex that's fully in
gear yet either and is not in a position
to convince them yet at somebody else's
problem look the other way that's why
young adults are exactly how they are
because the frontal cortex isn't quite
there yet and what you have as a result
is more adventurousness and more open to
novelty and more likelihood of seeing
somebody who is very different as in
fact not so being that different after
all and more likely to grab a cudgel and
smash in somebody's skull who happens to
seem like of them and everything just
the tone of everything is pushed up one
incredibly important implication of that
is if the frontal cortex is the lost
last part of the brain to fully mature
that means it's the part of the brain
that is most sculpted by in
and experience and least constrained by
genes and it's the most interesting part
of the brain meanwhile look at the other
end of it look at sixty year olds and
what's going on there if you were a
sixty year old human or say a rat
equivalent of a 60 year old you were far
more close to novelty than a 20 year old
then an adolescent rat is take a rat for
example and see at what points in life
is it willing to try a new food and
exactly the equivalent of late teenage
years early adulthood and then you close
the novelty any species out there shows
that pattern and clean humans so a 60
year old is resistant to change is
resistant to somebody else's novelty a
60 year old unlike a 20 year old deals
with stress in a very particular way if
you're 20 what stress management is
about is trying to overcome the stressor
and defeat it if you're 60 what stress
management is about is learning to
accommodate what things you're not going
to be able to change and there's nothing
you can do about the fact that your
knees hurt like hell and it's
accommodating it's learning the
difference between what you can change
and what you can't if you're 20 there's
nothing in the world we can't change by
the time you're 60 what knowledge which
intelligence is mostly about is
crystallized fact-based knowledge and
crystallized strategies for dealing with
that knowledge what a 20 year old
intelligence is about is fluid
improvising changing of set reversing of
orders all of that is a very very
different sort of picture 20 and 60 year
old brains and 20 and six-year-old
social worms are remarkably different
[Music]